Voiceover:Let's say that
you're throwing a party,
and as we all know, any party needs
a sufficient number of monkeys.
Right now you have 10 monkeys.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
But you would like to have 18 monkeys.
How many more monkeys do you need
in order to have 18 monkeys?
I encourage you to pause the video and
think about it on your own before
I work through it.
Remember, the goal here is to get to ...
The goal here ...
Let me write it this way.
The goal here is to get to 18, 18 monkeys.
Now what do we know about the number 18?
Well the number 18, you have this 1
right over here in the tens place.
That literally represents 1, 10.
And then this 8 represents 8, 1's.
Plus 8, 1's.
That's the same thing as saying 1, 10 ...
1, 10, that's just a 10 right over there.
And 8, 1's, that's just 8.
18 is the same thing as 10 plus 8.
If we start with 10
monkeys, which is how many
we have started with, how many more
do we need to get to 18?
Well, if you start at 10, you need 8 more
to get to 18.
We can verify that visually, if we like.
Let's see.
Let me copy and paste 1 of these monkeys.
Copy.
This is 10.
Now, let's get to 18.
11, 12, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, and 18.
And 18.
How many more did we add?
Well, once again, we started, we started
with this 10 right over here.
Let me box them off.
We started with these 10 monkeys.
That's 1 group of 10 right over there.
We started with the 10.
And then we added 8 more monkeys.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So we started with 10.
We added 8 more monkeys.
We added 8 more monkeys
to get, to get to 18.
And once again, how did we first think
about that?
Well, 18 is 1, 10 plus 8, 1's.
Or 10 plus 8.